un paysage onirique au lever du jour
entourées par les eaux le mont saint
michel à des rendez-vous sur terre avec
ses admirateurs dans le ciel avec les
astres c'est magique avec un en
correspondance à la lune le soleil très
belle lumière très bon moment certains
viennent du bout du monde pour assister
à ce spectacle
d'autres ont parcouru quelques
kilomètres on est pourtant de la région
c'est la première fois qu'on est venu
voir le mont grandes marées
c'est magnifique au sommet de la
merveille resplendit l'archange il a
retrouvé son éclat et il est toujours là
et qui a bien sa place
les magnifiques c'est fabuleux avec avec
l'or qui était mis dessus et la lumière
c'est vraiment très très beau pour vivre
cet instant de paix il fallait être au
pied du mont des huit heures du matin on
s'est levés tôt pour venir le voir
du coup ça valait la peine je trouve
cette jolie et pitt voir la mer
qui monte et qui descend serait comme si
c'était moi j'étais patient fait hier un
bout du pont qui revient qui disparaît
c'était un des derniers plus forts
coefficients de grandes marées de
l'année
le mont-saint-michel redeviendra une île
dès ce soir